أَشْكَالْ أَشْكَالْ أَشْكَالْ أَشْكَالْ
غَنُّوا يا أَطْفَاْل  أَسْمَاءَ الأَشْكَالْ
شكلي يشبه الشمس
احزروا من أكون
دَائِرَةْ
داا داا دَائِرَةْ
داا داا دااا دائرة
كالشَّمسِ مُدَوَّرَةْ أنا أنا أنا الدَّائِرةْ
دائرة    هاااي
لدي أربعة أضلاع متساوية
من أكون
مُرَبَّعْ
مو مو مُرَبَّعْ
مو مو مو مربع
أَرْبَع أضلاع يا ناس
متساوية في القياس
مربع   هاااي
لا لا لا لا لا لا لا لا لا لا لا لا
نحن الأشكال
أضلاعي ثلاثة فقط
ترى من أكون
مُثَلَّثْ
مو مو مُثَلَّثْ
مو مو مو مثلث
مِثْلَ مُثَلَّثِ الإِيقَاعْ
عندي ثَلاَثَةُ أَضْلاعْ
مثلث   أجل
أشبه شكل الباب
من أكون
مُسْتَطِيلْ
مو مو مُسْتَطِيلْ
مو مو مو مستطيل
يُشْبِهُنِي شَكْلُ الأَبْوَابْ
وَكَشَكْلِ النَّافِذَةِ جَمِيلْ
مستطيل هاااي
أَشْكَالْ أَشْكَالْ أَشْكَالْ أَشْكَالْ
غَنُّوا يا أَطْفَاْل  أَسْمَاءَ الأَشْكَالْ